what I have here is the list of ages of
the students in a class and what I want
to explore in this video is different
ways of representing this data and then
see if we can answer questions about the
data so the first way we can think about
it is as a frequency table frequency
table frequency table and what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
each for each age for each possible age
that we've measured here see how many
students in the class are of that age so
we could say the age is one column and
then the number the number of students
of that age or we could even say the
frequency frequency when people say how
frequent do you do something they're
saying how often does it happen how
often do you do that thing frequency or
we could also say actually I'm just
right number I'm always a fan of the
simpler number at age which we could
also consider the frequency at that age
frequency of students all right so
what's the lowest age that we have here
well the lowest age is five so I'll
start with five and how many students in
the class are age five how frequent is
the number five let's see there is one
two let me keep scanning looks like
there's only two fives so I could write
a two here there are two fives and now
let's go to six
how many sixes are there let's see there
is one six there's only one six-year-old
in the class all right seven year-olds
see there's one two three four seven
year-olds for seven year olds now what
about eight year olds eight year olds
I'm going to do this in a color that I
have not used yet eight year olds we
have no eight year olds zero eight year
olds and then we have nine year olds
let's see nine year olds we have one two
three four nine year olds for nine year
olds ten year olds what do we have
have one ten-year-old right over there
and then 11 year olds 11 year olds there
are no 11 year olds and then let me
scroll up a little bit and then finally
12 year olds 12 year olds there are one
to twelve year olds so what we have just
constructed is a frequency table it's a
frequency table you can see you can see
for each age how many students are at
that age so it's giving you the same
information as we have up here you could
take this table and construct what we
have up here you would just write down
two fives one six four sevens no eights
four nines
one 10 no 11s and two twelves and then
you wouldn't just have this list of
numbers now a way to visually look at a
frequency table you could is a dot plot
so let me draw a dot plot right over
here so a a dot plot and a dot plot we
essentially just take the same
information and even think about it the
same way but we just show it visually so
in a dot plot what we would have and the
dot plot what we would have of actually
I would let me just not draw any venero
there we have the different age groups
so 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 and 12 and we have a
dot to represent or we use a dot for
each student at that age so there's two
five year olds so I'll do two dots one
and two there's one six-year-old so
that's going to be one dot right over
here there's four seven year-olds so one
two three four dots
there's no eight-year-olds there's four
nine year olds so one two three and four
there's one ten year old so let's put a
dot one dot right over there for that
one ten-year-old there's no eleven year
old so I'm not going to put any dots
there and then there's two twelve year
olds so one twelve year old
and another 12 year old so there you go
we have frequency table dot plot list of
numbers these are all showing the same
data just in different ways and once you
have it represented in any of these ways
we can start to ask questions about it
so we could say what is the most
frequent age well the most frequent age
when you look at it visually though or
the easiest thing might be just look at
the dot plot cuz you see it visually the
most frequent age are the two highest
acts so there's actually seven and nine
our free are tied for the most frequent
age you would have also seen it here
where seven and nine are tied at four
and if you just had this data you would
actually need have to count all of them
to kind of come up with this again and
say okay there's four sevens four 9s
that's the largest number so this is if
you're looking for what's the most
frequent age when you just visually
inspect here probably pops out at you
the fastest but there's other questions
we can ask ourselves we can ask
ourselves what is the range what is the
range of Ages in the classroom and this
is once again where maybe the dot plot
is the most it jumps out at you the most
because the range is just the maximum
age in your or the maximum data point
minus the minimum data point so what's
the maximum age here well the maximum
age here we see it from this from the
dot plot is 12 and the minimum age here
you see is five so there's a range of
seven the difference between the maximum
and the minimum is seven but you could
have also done that over here you can
set a the maximum age here is 12 minimum
age here is five and so subtract from
Twitter from five you said you find the
difference between 12 and 5 which is 7
here you do not have to do it you could
still kind of done it except what's the
lowest let's look at 5 are there any
fours here no there's no 4 so 5 0 mage
and what's the larger says it 7 knows it
9
9 9 10 12 12 are there any 13s no 12 is
the maximum so you say 12 minus 5 is 7
to get the range but that we could ask
ourselves other questions we could say
how many how many older older than 9 is
a question we could we could ask
ourselves and then if we were to look at
the dot plot we say ok this is 9 and we
care about how many are older than 9 so
that would be this 1 2 & 3 or you could
look over here how many are older than 9
what's the one person who's 10 and then
the two who are 12 so there are three
and over here if you said how many are
older than 9 you well then you would
just have to go through the list and say
okay no no no no no no no okay here 1 2
3 into the knot that person right over
there
so hopefully you this is just an
appreciation for yet another two ways of
looking at data frequency tables and dot
plots